hallo mein name ist sogar herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video ihr seht schon sicher eingeblendet
yoga challenge mit einem model deswegen
habe ich mir grad ist ein oder anderen
worten you got challenges [ __ ] wir
haben uns dazu sechs verschiedene yoga
posen rausgesucht die wird versuchen
miteinander zu machen müssen die
unterarme von hinten geschafft
ich weiß schon wieder nicht wie wir das
machen soll muss irgendwie vorne sein
und war niederreiter okay ich mache erst
mal den vorderen 43 sekunden später
3 das nächste ist ich weiß nicht einmal
was wieder unten ich würd sagen diesmal
nach unten
gemerkt wie noch durch doping und muss
der kopf runter wie soll ich mich da
draußen ich wenig zeit aber wir uns
gedacht wir wollen unbedingt dieses
video mal wieso steht der vierte juni
2006 investierte juni 2010 extra dance
tracks aber wir wollten unbedingt dieses
video fertig machen deswegen jetzt
nächste yoga position
somebody rototec yoga martina chollima
das nächste uns nicht verarschen
ich kann das mit kopf-an-kopf okay also
ich muss auf jeden fall irgendwie hin
bewusst die beine
hier klicken das klappt schon früher
beenden die malerin so sollen und
anderen vorbei genau und jetzt
du musst die nada muss irgendwie echt
kann das überhaupt nicht mit so einem
rad schlagen
es ist eine fackel brücke muss sich hoch
drei dafür musst du drei jahre gymnastik
machen warum suche ich an so was raus
sorry falls das video ein bisschen
chaotisch waren freunde aber eigentlich
wollte ich heute gar nicht so relativ
kräftige park war dann haben uns aber
gedacht ja wir nehmen trotzdem die yoga
challenge auch wenn solch gefallen hat
würden wir definitiv aber live freuen
wenn es ganz normal volt ein bisschen
professioneller dann schreibt einfach
ordentlich kommentare martin us kanal
ist der schreibung verlinkt und